Chris Christie is announcing that he
will run against Donald Trump in the
Republican primary I have to tell you
I'm not a republican I will almost
certainly not vote for a republican in
the 2024 presidential election but if
you came to me with tears in your eyes
and said sir you have to pick only from
the Republican candidates who do you
want to see as the next president my
choice from the current slate of
Republicans would be Chris Christie not
only is he a good debater not only can
he make fools look stupid as he has done
many times before but he's a smart guy
and a former prosecutor and a more
moderate Republican compared to some of
these other extremists by virtue of
having been the governor of New Jersey
is he hugely corrupt of course uh would
I prefer someone on the left absolutely
but from the Republicans that are
running it's hard to find a better
choice than Chris Christie it certainly
wouldn't be DeSantis it absolutely
wouldn't be Trump and everybody else is
just so uninspiring